Speaker 1: Last night, Joe Biden delivered
his first speech to a joint session of Congress,
the Senate coming over to the House of Representatives
to hear Joe Biden deliver this speech, not
called the State of the Union.
It's typically not called the State of the
Union when it's a president's first year in
office, but it is essentially a State of the
Union.
And Joe Biden did lay out his plan for a one
point eight trillion dollar spending package,
including funding paid leave, community college
and all of the things we previewed in some
detail yesterday.
So I won't redo the policy proposal nitty
gritty again.
But it was overall a very policy heavy speech.
This could not have been more different from
recent State of the Union addresses from Donald
Trump, which contained almost no policy but
Trump aside even compared to Barack Obama.
Compared to George W. Bush before him, it
was really just a focus on policy with very
little vapid political rhetoric.
Now, that's not necessarily good or bad.
Vapid political rhetoric can be a good thing
if it's inspirational or coalesces people
or it can be nonsense or whatever.
But this was really a focus on policy, a focus
on vaccination.
Even Ted Cruz here applauding after Joe Biden
announces 220 million vaccine doses in 100
days and urges everybody to get themselves
vaccinated.
Speaker 2: Right now, right away.
Go get vaccinated, America.
Go and get the vaccination there available.
Eligible now.
Speaker 1: Joe Biden talking about those vaccination
numbers, but also talking a lot about job
creation,
Speaker 2: all this is all going on, the economy
creating more than one million, 300000 new
jobs and 100 days more jobs in the first.
More jobs in the first 100 days than any president
on record.
The International Monetary Fund.
Speaker 1: To international now, of course,
that is true, context does matter.
We were and are in a recovery period from
an externally motivated job loss caused by
the pandemic.
Now, many of those jobs are coming back.
You expect any president to brag about job
growth, whether or not they had a hand in
it, it is still a good thing.
But it is important to understand the context.
Many of these jobs would be coming back regardless
of who was president.
I'd rather it be Joe Biden than Donald Trump
for sure.
Joe Biden then jumping right into talking
about the economy and talking about the importance
of unions, much to Bernie Sanders delight
Speaker 2: and unions built the middle class.
So that's why I'm calling on Congress.
To pass, protect the right to organize, act,
the pro act and send it to my desk so we can
support the right to unionize.
And by the way,
Speaker 1: and Joe Biden then, much to the
pleasure of most Democrats in the crowd, but
not Mitt Romney and Lauren Bobert and others
saying let's raise the minimum wage to fifteen
dollars an hour,
Speaker 2: let's raise the minimum wage to
15 dollars.
No one.
No one working 40 hours a week, no one working
40 hours a week should live below the poverty
line.
We need to ensure greater equity and opportunity
for women while we're doing this.
Let's get the Paycheck Fairness Act to my
desk as well.
Equal pay.
Spent much too long.
And you wonder whether it's too long.
Look behind
Speaker 1: you.
Joe Biden also laying out how he will pay
for much of these ideas, saying the rich will
pay.
And Mitt Romney didn't seem particularly thrilled
with that either.
Speaker 2: And the wealthiest one percent
of Americans have just begun to pay their
fair share, just their fair share.
Sometimes I have arguments with my friends
in the Democratic Party.
I think you should be able to become a billionaire
and a millionaire, but pay your fair share.
Speaker 1: And on economics, a moment that
many people liked, which got a lot of attention.
Joe Biden saying straight up trickle down
economics has never worked.
Speaker 2: My fellow Americans, trickle down,
trickle down economics has never worked this
time to grow the economy from the bottom in
the middle out.
Speaker 1: Now, I love this because I already
planned later today to talk about Joe Biden
and biodynamics as they are being called,
as the antithesis to Reaganomics, that line
trickle down economics has never worked, is
actually part of it, saying it as directly
as anybody can.
And we're going to come back to that in more
detail on foreign policy.
Joe Biden pointing out that he's just getting
out of Afghanistan, something that Republicans
loved when it was Trump who announced that
Trump failed to do it.
Joe Biden is doing it and Republicans are
no longer clapping about it.
Speaker 2: And American leadership means ending
the forever war in Afghanistan.
Unidentified: We have.
We have.
Speaker 2: Without hyperbole, the greatest
fighting force in the history of the world,
I'm the first president in 40 years who knows
what it means to have a son serving in a war
zone.
Today, we have service members serving in
the same war zone as their parents did.
We have service members in Afghanistan who
are not yet born on 9/11.
The war in Afghanistan, as we remember, the
debates here were never meant to be multigenerational
undertakings of nation building.
Speaker 1: Of course, it was never really
about just getting out of Afghanistan.
It was can we cheer for something Trump is
doing?
Biden now is actually going to do the thing.
We cheered Trump for announcing, but we don't
share anymore because we are merely political
hypocrites.
Real quick, here is Senator Ted Cruz sleeping
during the speech.
He looked very, very sleepy, apparently dreaming
of Cancun and Joe Biden ultimately closing
out his speech.
Take a listen to that.
Speaker 2: It's never, ever, ever been a good
bet to bet against America.
And it still isn't where the United States
of America.
There's not a single thing, nothing, nothing
beyond our capacity.
We can do whatever we set our minds to if
we do it together.
So let's begin to get together.
God bless you all and may God protect our
troops.
Thank you for your patience.
Speaker 1: Some of the people in the camp
of Biden is a weakling and he's old and senile
and demented, we're expecting a very short
speech and a very incoherent speech.
Biden going much longer than recent presidents
have during their first joint addresses to
Congress and very coherent.
I thought it was a well-written speech.
I thought it was about the right duration.
I often think things are too long.
I think it was about the right duration.
And now actually comes the tough part, which
is Joe Biden has laid out a variety of different
policy ideas.
Can Joe Biden get any of what he proposed
done?
And that is certainly easier said than done
when not only do you have zero Republican
support in the House and Senate for anything
you want to do, but it's not even clear you
have the support of all of the Democrats in
the Senate either.
And we will talk about that is these proposals
become more formalized and start to be debated.